hey leute und willkommen zum ersten part
der serie meine meinung in dieser serie
werde ich einen meiner meine eigene
meinung einfach zu irgend einem
bestimmten thema zu einer bestimmten
person wegen einer bestimmten handlung
einfach öffentlich preisgeben und ich
hoffe dass ihr das respektiert das ist
meine meinung sage ich sofort eure
meinung kann anders sein schreibt mir
eure meinung einfach in die kommentare
und ich bitte euch nicht jetzt über mich
robe zu helfen oder über irgendwelche
anderen fakten die ich hier sage wie
gesagt es ist alles nur meine meinung
deswegen als die serie auch so und je
von jedem menschen die meinung ist
anders von daher
naja ich werde einfach mal direkt
anfangen uns was das heutige thema
julians blog elfte september bzw
allgemeinen julians block und zwar finde
ich dass ich würde sagen ich habe mir
direkt von vorne an und zwar habe ich
julians block am boden war dass ich hab
ihn abonnierte hatte er könig zu 15.000
bis 20.000 abonnenten das ist noch gar
nicht so lange her
denn er hat ja erlebt ja momentan einen
richtigen push in deutschland sage ich
mal das sieht man ja an den abo zuwachs
wenn man einfach mal auf seinen kanal
über ein paar tage hinweg guckt das ist
da schon immens sich viele neue
abonnenten er dazu gewinnt und also ich
kann sagen ich habe ihnen damals
abonnierte hat er so ungefähr 20.000
30.000 abonnenten so um den dreh und das
war damals so die zeit hat er videos
hochgeladen gehabt wie julien versus
bild und halt ganz normale web analysen
und sowas und das fand ich einfach
richtig genial weil das waren quasi so
dokus bzw
analysen und das auf einem richtig
richtig hohem niveau mal und richtig
professionell gekettet mit
professionellen beat mitbericht ich
guten witz die aufgepasst haben
und allein die webanalyse vor dann
teilweise ich weiß nicht ich glaube zu
kollege was habe ich eine dreiviertel
stunde oder so einfach alles analysiert
hat das war locker arbeit von mehreren
wochen so etwas auf die beine zu stellen
und sowas fand ich einfach genial
qualität aber zwar nicht quantität aber
durch finde
allein wenn man diese qualität nicht hat
steigert sich die qualität auch immer
mehr weil man sich vielmehr auf ein
neues video dann freut das waren die
zeiten julien welches bild kennt
wahrscheinlich manche auch nicht mehr
die nun neue abonnenten von ihm sind
das war eine serie da hat er sich als
spezielle artikel aus der welt
rausgenommen und hat diese dann auch
durch analysiert wie zum beispiel
falsche falsches zitieren zum beispiel
oder allgemein
history für die bild gelogen hat und
auch oder andere dinge hintergangen
haben und so weiter völlig auf jeden
fall richtig genial doch dann mit den
abonnenten und mit der zeit wurde er
bisher immer arroganter dann habe ich
ihn der abonniert und gucke nur noch
manchmal auf seinen kanal und ich weiß
jetzt kommen wieder alle an mit blabla
solltest du schwarze moor satire ironie
und so gut soweit ich weiß dass er das
immer behauptet aber für mich hat ironie
und schwarzem humor und satire und
allgemein sarkasmus als mar group
umfasst irgendwann ist das eine grenze
sondern siedepunkt beziehungsweise zum
tropfen der das fass zum überlaufen
bringt und wenn diese grenze nicht
eingehalten wird dann wird es sehr oft
falsch verstanden
ich finde dass julian mittlerweile diese
grenze in fast jedem video überschreitet
was kann ich dann zum beispiel nehmen
irgendwie in einem video hat er übels
über schwarze abgelästert dass die ja in
afrika total schlimm sein dass man die
alle umbringen sollte und dass er dann
ganz viele schwarze blut mittelmeer
gemalt hat oder irgendwie sowas oder
jetzt auch bei elfter september das ist
ja das aktuellste beispiel womit
wahrscheinlich meist noch was anfangen
können wo er einfach gesagt hat dass der
elfte september wie nun ein feiertag ist
ich weiß jetzt kommen wieder alle an das
ist ja ironie war dass er dass er gar
nicht so meint aber ich finde es
trotzdem heftig weil ich meine wenn nun
da jemand zugeguckt hat er irgendwie an
dem elften september mitbeteiligt war
was bestimmt der fall war auch wenn es
ein paar personen waren aber die zb zu
der zeit irgendwie new york waren oder
die da irgendwelche freunde oder
bekannte verloren haben stellt euch mal
vor wie das für euch ist ich meine das
ist genauso wie wenn ihr eine person
verliert die ihr extrem liebt sag ich
mal über alles und jemand macht sich
darüber lustig wie diese person
gestorben ist sage ich mal der der
feiert das quasi noch dass diese
personen alle tot sind und ich finde
dann wenn man sich das mal so überlegt
dann hat das video in ganz anderen
stellenwert und ich weiß nicht wie ich
das auch ziemlich oft aber allem ein
wirklich immer und er mal dass auch dass
das ganze so sackers muss und dass wir
alle viel zu blöd sind um das zu
kapieren
ich weiß dass es nur sarkasmus ich bin
nicht dazu zu blöd aber ich find's
einfach nur schrecklich wie hoch dieser
sarkasmus dieser sarkasmus grenze bei
ihm gesetzt ist ich weiß auch nicht mehr
wie man darüber einfach nur lachen kann
letztens war ein geniales video wieder
wo er gegen
die website eltern im netz vorgegangen
ist das finde ich genial solche videos
das erinnerte mich so an die alten
analyse zeiten aber solche videos wie
zum beispiel jetzt elfter september
finde ich einfach nur schrecklich wo er
sich einfach da oder oder welche
menschen er gerne umbringen möchte das
geht aus einem video
ich meine dass er menschen im kino
umbringen will die irgendwie laut sind
oder so das ist dann sagt man mal kurz
weil ich weiß ich weiß es ist ironie
aber ich find's einfach viel zu heftig
ich weiß auch dass seelsorge diese serie
einfach nur ein kompletter fake war und
dass die ganzen nachrichten wie zum
beispiel herrlich hat den letzten sex
mit dem hamster oder irgend sowas war ja
auch dass das alles nicht stimmt aber
ich finde es trotzdem heftig dass er
einfach zu jedem jedem hat er empfohlen
bring dich um dein leben hat keinen sinn
wenn er dann wirklich einer ist der
wirklich total traurig ist und wirklich
depressionen hat und er guckt sich sowas
an
ich will gar nicht wissen was er danach
macht aber das möchte ich jetzt gar
nicht weiter erläutern ich finde es
einfach nur heftig wie julien sarkasmus
betreibt sage ich mal ich sag mal
wirklich sarkasmus in anführungszeichen
finde ich einfach viel zu heftig und
allein schon beim elften september
wieder dass er den elfter september als
feiertag predigt dass er behinderte
tritt dass er sich über behinderte und
die toten dort lustig macht und so
weiter finde ich einfach nur total
schrecklich finde ich sollte verboten
werden auf youtube so was und naja ich
hab selber unter das video dann auch
einen kommentar geschrieben habe
versucht mich sachlich zu halten weil
ich einfach total aufgebracht war und
ich werde ihn euch mal ganz kurz
einblenden
der war auch glaube ich mehrere tage top
kommentiert und na ja ich lese ihnen
einfach mal vor julien ich glaube uns
allen ist mehr oder minder bewusst dass
dein track die lions die reime und
soweit auf höchsten niveau sind
allerdings hört man einen song nicht nur
wegen der technik sondern auch wegen der
stimme und deine stimme ist zum rappen
beziehungsweise singen einfach mal
überhaupt nicht geeignet
du kannst über geile analysen reportagen
et cetera produzieren und aufnehmen aber
bitte lasst das mit dem rappen kontrakte
also das war nochmal alles was ich
vorhin gesagt habe ganz kurz
zusammengefasst und zwar wie ich vorhin
schon meinte ich finde die alten
analysen und studien weises bild echt
extrem haben wir von ihm weil einfach
die perfekte stimme zu moderieren
kommentieren hat oder er könnte super
irgendwie bei n-tv welche
reportagen leiten wenn er da mal ein
bisschen ruhiger sein würde aber ich
find sowas ist einfach genial dadurch
ist er bekannt geworden und mittlerweile
wird ist zwar immer noch bekannt habe
ich frag mich mittlerweile warum weil er
alle möglichen leute beleidigt ich weiß
es nicht
die qualität ist wie immer top aber ich
finde damit durch die neuesten videos
mittlerweile wo er meint er sei der
geilste und erst der die beste person
auf erden und die anfänger sind
schlechte sollten umgebracht werden und
er kann ja rappen und so toll ist dass
er alles bei ihm finde ich passt nicht
irgendwie zu ihm und ich finde er sollte
aufhören mit solchen übelsten heftigen
videos und sich mehr auf alte gute
videos konzentriert die dann vielleicht
auch mal ein bisschen länger brauchen
und endlich mal wieder eine neue web
analyse machen weil das ist so das was
er am besten kann analysen und
reportagen und sowas und das war jetzt
erstmal so meine meinung zu julians blog
ich habe persönlich nichts gegen ihn
aber ich finds halt ein bisschen schade
wie er sich entwickelt hat weil er auf
jeden fall viel mehr drauf hat als er
zur zeit wirklich macht und ich würde
einfach mal sagen wenn ihr mehr von
solchen meinung wie deus haben wollt
dann schreibt es in die kommentare
ich würde mich waren daumen hoch freuen
und schreibt mir doch vielleicht mal
eure meinung zu lienz block in die
kommentare und dann würde ich sagen
sehen uns beim nächsten mal